in ukraine where brutal russian attacks
are devastating entire communities this
video was taken shortly after bombs fell
on a children's hospital in the city of
mariopol you can see women from the
maternity ward being rescued from the
debris the world health organization
says at least 18 health providers have
been hit since russia invaded ukraine
vice president kamala harris is in
warsaw this morning the capital of
poland to meet with nato allies chris
livesay is reporting for us from odessa
in southern ukraine chris good morning
good morning nate ceaseless shelling
despite a ceasefire the latest blast in
mariopol killing at least three people
and wounding more than a dozen of the
city's most vulnerable civilians
ending life
where it's meant to begin
a maternity and children's hospital
bombed in the strategic port city of
maryupol
wounding doctors the young and the old
and trapping others beneath the rubble
pregnant women about to give birth now
running for cover a blood-stained
mattress broken incubators and a massive
crater make up all that's left of this
alleged war crime
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
they want us to feel like animals
because they blocked our cities the
biggest cities in ukraine and they
blocked and and because they don't want
our our people to get some food water
yet another ceasefire shattered one that
should have allowed civilians to escape
instead they're encircled by russian
firepower robbed of electricity water
heat and their dignity forced in the
panic to bury their dead in this mass
grave at least 1200 civilians have been
killed in the city since the war began
according to local officials
ukraine is not without its victories
seen here in its own footage repelling a
column of russian tanks outside kiev
while missiles continue to slam cities
like chautomir in the northwest
the most ferocious shelling as of late
has honed in on the south and the sea
today only one coastal stronghold
remains odessa a city of 1 million
people and the last domino on the
country's coastline lose it and ukraine
loses access to crucial supply lines
president zielinski warns an attack is
imminent
it's a city right in putin's crosshairs
one he specifically mentioned in his
declaration of war and odessa's been
bracing for a fight ever since
where the streets have no name anything
to slow down an invading army
one that's proven little is off limits
not even nuclear facilities active or
inactive like chernobyl ukraine warns
it's been completely cut off from the
power grid after falling into russian
hands on the first day of the invasion
to keep from overheating and possibly
leaking radiation the site of the
world's worst nuclear disaster in
history is now relying on backup
generators meant to last for only 48
hours they've now been running for a
full day
as if that weren't enough the white
house now warns that russia could be
planning a chemical or biological
weapons attack while framing it as a
false flag attack by the ukrainians as
the old saying goes the first casualty
of war is the truth nancy
such a frightening development chris
lives say in odessa thank you